[Music]
pastor mark the question is where do
seventh-day adventists fit in the
panorama of christian history i love
that question where does seventh-day
adventists fit in the panorama of
christian history
as you look back over time
after israel's apostasy god raised up
new testament christianity
when god raised up new testament
christianity the christian faith grew
and prospered you look at the book of
acts there's thousands that are being
baptized thousands that are coming to
christ the christian church is growing
satan began to persecute the christian
church he saw persecution didn't work
that well one of the christian leaders
tertilian said this
this the blood of the martyrs is the
seed of the gospel
then
the devil changed his tactics
he focused now not on persecution but on
compromise and when you look at the
fourth century the pagan emperor
constantine comes into the church
images come in contrary to the
commandment that says
thou shalt not worship images
idols come into the church
sunday worship comes into the church
there are a variety of false practices
that come into the church contrary to
the bible
that takes place in the 4th and 5th
centuries then you have that long period
of dark ages
after
the dark ages are coming now to the last
third you god raises up the waldenses
and they say obedience to god is our
motto not the church god raises up john
huss he says obedience the bible is my
god oh not my motto not the church god
raised up martin luther who understands
righteous by faith that was saved by
grace and not by works god ray begins to
raise up various leaders like john
wesley who said if we're saved by grace
that makes an impact on our lives god
raises up the anabaptists who believe
that
the
sprinkling is not in harmony with god's
will that we need to be baptized by
immersion so god began to raise up
different people there was a great
advent movement in the 1800s with
william miller in the united states
preaching jesus is coming soon
uh emmanuel acunza writing under the pen
name of rabbi ben ezra down in south
america preaching jesus is coming soon
edward irving had 300 preachers of the
church of england preaching jesus is
coming soon you look at joseph wolfe and
johann bengal where wolf is traveling
the world so what you have here is this
advent movement
out of all of this reformation
out of what waldenses did obedience to
god and what huss and jerome did of
faithfulness to the bible and and what
what luther did salvation by grace then
what the baptist did with baptism by
immersion and what the wesleyan
methodists did about standards and out
of all of that reformation in the second
coming of christ god raises up an end
time people
no
one group can understand all the truth
at once so the bible says proverbs 4
verse 18 the path of the just is like a
shining light that shines more and more
to the perfect day so at sunrise it's
not very light at it gets a little
lighter at nine a little lighter at 10 a
little lighter at 11 and pretty soon
it's the full light of the day so what's
god doing he is leading people along
gradually 1200 1300 1400 until we come
to the 1800s where god has a remnant
last day people that stand on the
shoulders of the reformation they accept
the great truths that have been
presented down through the ages and the
bible tells about this people
in two places revelation 12 verse 17 it
says the dragon that satan was roth or
angry with the church
went to make war with the remnant the
last part of her seed that is faithful
of course that keep the commandments of
god and of the testimony of jesus so god
would have a commandment keeping people
at end time
revelation 14 verse 12 says you say
where are they here are they that keep
the commandments of god of the faith of
jesus so god would have a bible
believing people that fall in love with
jesus that believe he's coming soon
again keeping his commandments including
the bible sabbath so seventh day
adventists believe
that they are the extension of the
reformation restoring truths long lost
sight of in the dark ages and to
proclaim that light of god to the world